it's useful for crypto users to use a
VPN and so that was one of my ideas
about we sold before we got around to
doing that that would have been cool if
you would have done that that would have
been that's a pretty cool move
too bad
[Music]
all right what's up we got John Coogan
here uh John somebody who I only know
through a lunch at a Mexican restaurant
in La and that's the best way to meet
anybody who's gonna be a podcast guest
so uh you you got a crazy background
I'll give people The Rundown if they
don't know who who you are so you've uh
been an entrepreneur your whole life
never had a job
started two companies that were both
really interesting Soylent which was
basically making a uh a meal replacement
drink is the easiest way to explain it
tasted like the milk of Honey Nut
Cheerios which I always appreciated and
then Lucy gum which was like a nicotine
gum both of them went through YC
together they've raised over 130 million
dollars a bunch of good lessons there
um you're also an eir at Founders fund
which is one of the more interesting
places to to kind of hang out or be a
part of and uh like us you've made the
mistake of leaving entrepreneurship to
just be a YouTuber and this is great so
you know how to make content too which
is which is amazing you make really
awesome videos uh Sam was sending me one
this morning Sam you like his stuff huh
I love it yeah I like your stuff John I
uh by the way Sean I'm an investor of
Lucy so I gotta get that out of the way
and probably a user too at one point for
sure but I mean I think you did invest
like four years ago so you know the fact
that I haven't been on yet I think I
earned my stripes by posting on YouTube
playing in the content world you know
yeah what is your guys I don't even know
can you say the valuation is I think I
invested 25 000 at a 10 million
evaluation and ten yeah you were
probably in like this seed round and now
the company's worth like 60 70 mil all
right on paper I've made a little bit of
money yeah not bad we had I think we
could tell this story we had one of the
other co-founders of Lucy come on the
Pod once and this guy we had met him at
a at some like event maybe a hustle
event so some some night time event and
this guy was holding course that was
Dave Dave yeah he was telling stories
there's five people around him he's got
ideas yeah he's like oh there needs to
be something called Pleasure Island and
it's a place where you could just go sin
and I was like Wow who is this guy what
is he talking about and he's telling
stories he's amazing everybody's just in
captured by this guy I'm like we gotta
have this guy at the Pod he comes on the
pod tells none of the stories and none
of the ideas he's like no I don't want
to test all those on the pond and we
were like dude and so I don't even think
we ever ran the episode because he
refused to tell the good stuff so John
will you make the same mistake as your
pal absolutely not I mean I I do think a
lot of Founders have a just a ton of
scar tissue built up from like the last
10 years of like the media just going
after Tech Founders and like Tech Bros
programmers like it was really
aggressive for a while there like
anything you said would be like taken
out of context putting some click bait
but now that Elon bought Twitter and
kind of just like caused enough chaos
like you can just say whatever you want
and there's like no I I I've been
telling every every founder I know like
cancel culture is over like don't worry
about things just say whatever you
believe so we're gonna do some of your
philosophy some of the the philosophies
like cancer culture is over but first
let's run through the background here
because both of these startups normally
we try not to spend too much time on the
guess with the background but yours both
are so interesting
um can you just tell us uh you know give
us the origin story for Soylent because
when this came out it was a very
different idea than anything I was
seeing anybody do in Silicon Valley
nobody was at that time this was maybe
2012 I had just moved to San Francisco
and
uh you had kind of like uber and Airbnb
but very few people were in the in the
San Francisco Venture Community were
doing like
like a like a drink or like a product
that you could eat you could drink
um that wasn't software based and but
still was Innovative and so it was like
kind of in this mix and I remember
Andrew said Horowitz got behind it and
some others and so it was a very
interesting thing and I think it started
out of like a hacker house right like
you guys had a crazy house is that right
yeah uh I mean a bunch of funny stories
from that this was the yeah Warby Parker
was like the first e-commerce company to
kind of think about it from like a tech
first angle uh we were a couple years
after them
um right around the same era as like
Dollar Shave Club if you remember that
company
um but yeah we met in a hacker house uh
my my co-founder and I we went to
preschool middle school high school
together went to college in the same
city and so we moved out to Silicon
Valley we're looking for a place we find
something on uh like Craigslist it's
like an Airbnb listing and they're like
this place is incredible it's got a pool
it's got five bedrooms it's exactly like
the social network you're gonna love it
we show up the pool is filled with algae
the bathrooms don't work it's just
absolute squalor so we grind for like
six months there eventually we moved to
the tenderloin which is an even nicer
community and and uh we're living in
technically a one bedroom with three
guys so I I was living in the living
room another guy uh Rob the guy who
actually came up with the idea for
Soylent he was living what was
technically a closet because it didn't
have a window and we were just we were
just hacking we were just not a lot of
dating going on yeah not a lot of dating
um not a lot of anything just wake up
program go to sleep wake up program go
to sleep and we just had sticky notes on
the wall being like okay after this idea
fails we'll build this next idea all all
the worst ideas you've ever heard on
here when people come on and they give
you their bad ideas like
like we were building the mall and they
were all failing give us a couple what
were they like take a picture and it
puts it through a filter and it puts it
on a shirt and it like mails you the
shirt like it's just like weird stuff
like that there were some ideas that
were good they were just like way before
their time like uh do you know Google
stadia it allows you to play video games
and the cloud streams it to you like we
basically built that but it was just
like five years too early and also we
didn't have a trillion dollars of data
centers for free like Google does so it
like and even stadia I think failed so
like even Google couldn't pull it off
and so of course we weren't going to be
able to get it done so there's just a
lot of those ideas where it was like too
early wrong team bad execution or just
terrible go to market like there were
some things that we built that were
pretty good but it just didn't work and
living with Rob living with Rob would be
odd because I know Rob he's he's a he's
so unique and eccentric and weird and in
such an interesting way yeah so he'd
been writing on his blog and posting on
Hacker News and he wrote a bunch of
basically viral clickbait targeted at
programmer so he speaking of dating he
wrote a a a blog post saying how he
hacked Tinder and and he was saying this
was before like Bots and stuff so he
basically claimed he didn't really do
this it was more just like for satire
and for fun but he said he wrote a
script that would automatically swipe
right on everything and then and then
generative AI talked to this was like 10
years ago too but like talk to them talk
to the person and then it would use the
Uber API to call them a car and then he
would order doordash and deliver the
food and so like the the punch line at
the end of the at the end of the story
was basically like he wasn't involved at
all because it was like you know you can
you can imagine where that goes but
basically he had he built a little bit
of a following on Hacker News and so
when the the question was like we like
building these software companies we
like coding and building stuff launching
businesses but we are going to run out
of money and we're going to have to get
jobs so we need to look at our expenses
and understand where are we burning
money we paid a rent a year in advance I
think we were paying fifteen hundred
dollars for three dudes to live in the
heart of San Francisco oh like crazy low
money we owned our laptops paid our
internet bill like there was really no
cost other than food and so figuring out
how to get food as cheap as possible was
like a very logical you know conclusion
from that so Rob starts whipping up the
powders figures out this meal
replacement he's like instead of buying
a cheeseburger over here or some
groceries over there let me buy uh 200
pound sack of protein powder do you
remember that first conversation when
he's like guys I got it we'll just get a
bunch of powders and then that'll be the
food like is that yeah is that literally
or two they were yeah there were two
phases the first phase was he told me
like oh I'm I'm doing this diet
experiment I think it's going to make me
healthier I'm gonna you know monitor all
my macros and micros and start working
out and get in shape and I was just like
who cares what we look like like oh the
only thing that matters is like our code
and like our business ideas like we
don't we don't which is very stupid
because obviously you do need to be
healthy to like be productive
um so that was a stupid take by me
um but I kind of wrote it off and then
he kept doing it for a few weeks and
then we were at uh it's like a dinner
with a friend she'd made like homemade
sushi and I mean that's like a treat
when you're broke and he was like no I'm
not gonna eat I'm on this Soylent thing
and I was like this is crazy it's so I
mean it's sort of like that Brian
Johnson before Brian Johnson you know
yeah yeah yeah it's the stress test so
basically uh he told me that I was like
do you have a name for this and he was
like I'm calling it Soylent and I knew
the reference and I was like this genius
we need to sell this today like this is
like like this is going to be the market
entry strategy because it's going to be
so viral but yeah I mean he basically
did a stress test he lived on it for 30
days and then people would just be like
yeah I think this ingredient's stupid or
I think this is bad but like hey if you
survived 30 days only on this like I can
probably take a sip and see how it
tastes and so it created this curiosity
when we launched my content company the
hustle one of the first early viral
video uh viral you uh articles was I
paid a guy two G's to live on it for 30
days while he was running 70 miles a
week as like a amateur Runner yeah may
he rest in peace yeah
and that's what made the story go viral
the the silent thing that was the gift
that kept on giving particularly I mean
for me as well you know like I I I got
traffic from it too yeah and it was it
was like a left right issue everybody
hated it uh and then you'd post it and
then this was back in the day when like
the Facebook algorithm was like entirely
comment driven so people would correct
us and they'd be like oh you made a
mistake you name you accidentally named
your company after a movie with Charlton
Heston in it that's a sci-fi movie and
it's like no obviously we did that on
purpose like what are you talking about
but that the fact that there would be
that comment and then another person
would come in and be like oh well
there's actually this book and somebody
like oh you need to fire your marketing
people be like oh I actually got the
reference and then they'd be talking
every single time we posted anything in
addition to all the comments about is
this good is this bad what does it mean
for society so just massive viral fuel
any any article went viral and so we
were able to kind of trade up the chain
and go from Vice news to you know the
hustle to BBC to the New York Times
times New Yorker and then eventually Rob
was on The Colbert Report with sitting
next to Stephen Colbert is crazy well
it's definitely shows the power of a
viral product but also it was my first
time learning about signal so like I had
never bought a fancy watch or a car or
jacket or anything but the first time I
was seeing you holding a Soylent it was
like this crazy signal was going out to
the world I was like I'm in Tech first
of all you know that just by this drink
you don't have to ask anything else all
right maybe you've looked at this brown
guy in San Francisco probably would have
guessed that one okay what what else
does it tell you it tells you like I
value productivity yeah Brown guy it's
Selma you know like backpack is like
sagging to the back of my knees with
somebody like accessories so so then
it's like number two is like you value
productivity over yep things like taste
maybe even things like Health right like
oh yeah everything yeah yeah so it's a
value signal then it was like a
contrarian signal and it was like I
don't give a [__] what you think about
me signal it was so powerful as a
signaling tool for like this one year
period yeah but that actually Cuts both
ways because food is such a signal and
there's so much badge value it's very
hard to accrue like Monopoly power and
how do you actually go about disrupting
Nestle if if every if every food is like
an extension of personal expression it
gets very hard because as soon as
everyone is doing one thing I'm going to
want to do something different and so
there's this constant like ping-ponging
in these products so it's very very hard
to create like one brand to rule them
all you said something about Peter Thiel
uh talk to me and for one in one hour he
diagnosed everything that would go wrong
in my business was that about Soylent
yeah
what did what did Peter tell you yeah I
mean we went in for like the pitch and
sat down and did like kind of a working
session and uh I mean now everyone knows
the framework because he's written the
book zero to one it's it's like
incredibly popular everyone kind of
knows that you know the the way Venture
back companies accrue value is through
moats the development of moats and you
know the Hamilton Helmer has the powers
framework Peter has you know different
um different Theses around this and and
we know the basics it's like you know
brand intellectual property complex
coordination scale economies Network
economies right Network effects and so
but at this time in 2013 everyone
thought that there would just be a
magical Network effect that would show
up and that's just not true like so
there was this weird dynamic where you
know a lot of investors that we talked
to were like oh yeah like you don't need
to advertise you can just like like the
people like it so much that they'll sell
it to each other and that's true in a
multi-level marketing scheme but it's
not true if you don't build that
infrastructure to make that happen so we
never we never achieved like escape
velocity there and he was just kind of
like yeah like this is just a widgets
business like run this like a you know
any other business like you need to sell
like you have product Market fit which
we did like you just need to maximize
you know your like run the Playbook of
you know Market bring the customer in
make sure you're bringing them in
cheaper he was basically like this is a
great lifestyle business guys congrats
and and then we raised a bunch of
venture and it was a disaster what was
your Peak what was your Peak Revenue
like almost 100 Mil almost 100 Mil and
um I was reading you guys sold it
recently and yeah
not a good outcome all right I was gonna
say no disrespect but the outcome sucked
like for for how compared to the hype
and your Peak Revenue I think it was
like it was sold by a publicly traded
company did I read it was sold for 60
million dollars uh something I mean not
not a lot I I I I I actually like don't
even know the exact Dynamics because
there's a bunch of other like assets
that were like rolled up and it's part
of this combined thing but it was sold
for like maybe as much or less than you
raised you raised 100 million dollars
yeah exactly which basically means like
the common doesn't get anything got it
so you you didn't get much you didn't
get that wealthy from it yeah we got a
decent amount but not like what we
should have you know if we'd maximize
how to do that company but then you
started Lucy so Lucy is cool uh are you
there full time right now no I'm like
one day a week at Lucy
um mostly helping out with stuff like
this doing content and then ideally like
brokering deals with other content
creators like we want to do more we
being Founders fun uh no no me being
like the we being the Lucy team so to
give some background you know Soylent is
this nutrition product uh we run that
for four or five years and then Lucy is
a nicotine gum brand and nicotine pouch
brand so if you're if your viewers are
familiar with Zinn uh you know we're a
direct competitor is in but we
differentiate on Flavor strength and a
couple others dude
all day every day type of Zen guy yeah
yeah I imagine most people in the
audience are it's extremely I just wish
that Lucy sold it at 7-Eleven because
going to the gas stations like part of
my routine you know I gotta go see my
boys there and hang out and I mean 100
that is uh that is the name of the game
and that was what will actually unlock
like massive value in the Lucy business
100 people should know that by the way
when you when you email Sam you're like
hey I know you're a super busy guy and
someone to keep this brief Sam's busy at
7-Eleven shooting the [__] with his boys
on the curb those lotto tickets don't
scratch themselves my friend
he's is busy just in a different way
than you expect
I gotta drop off like a pallet of Lucy
at that exact 7-Eleven just be like here
it's free now Sam can get his well you
the the Lucy things are cool because
basically a Zen is just a pouch but uh
Lucy has it's called a breaker and so
you like bite into this and you get like
a little Menthol or something like a
flavor I love it I like the Citrus yeah
it's like it's like a liquid flavoring
so yeah I mean a lot of people complain
that the pouches although they're
they're much better than the pouch of
the previous years they dry your mouth
out and that's the number one complaint
so we figured it out you know how do we
address that well let's just actually
take liquid flavoring and put it inside
a capsule then and then when you break
it it moistens the pouch and then it
doesn't dry your mouth out gotcha all
right and let's talk about ideas so
those two ideas you did I would say are
the like top one percent of weirdo ideas
which means I love it and I love you
yeah what are your other weirdo ideas
that you're not doing uh you sent us a
couple of bullet points but explain them
so let's let's run through some of your
ideas yeah I mean I think the first one
that would be interesting to talk about
just because you know you guys are
obviously creating as well is
um just this idea of a creator-owned VPN
so we've seen that vpns might be the
number one Advertiser on YouTube I don't
have the exact stats but anyone who's
listened to a podcast or you watched a
YouTube video can probably name five
different vpns and yet none of them are
venture-backed there's not like one or
they're not like majorly Venture back
they're not big Venture winners there's
not like one that's running away have
you researched these guys yeah yeah a
little bit they're like all in Panama or
Maldo the the mod or what's it called
Moldova like Maldives I've tried looking
them up on um LinkedIn because I did a
ton of research on about this
specifically I did a lot of research on
the VPN review website so there was one
called compare Tech that was doing 14
million in Revenue 13 million in profit
like I saw their financials and they
sold yeah to a VPN company and I was
like these VPN companies are crazy uh
but I looked all up I looked up the
employees on LinkedIn and like you can't
find their employees on LinkedIn even
though they're companies that are doing
300 400 million dollars a year in
Revenue yeah yeah yeah it's a very very
odd space and basically like there's no
there's no big like Venture winner
there's no like oh Airbnb we all know
the CEO he's taking the company public
you know there's no like there's no like
front-facing company that's like oh this
one's winning and gonna run away with it
it's more like there's a bunch of them
they all print cash and there's not
really going to be one winner because
there's no network effect again it's uh
it's it doesn't have a big moat the moat
is marketing and that's why they all
spend on marketing and that's how they
differentiate is just you check all the
boxes how big are they easily easily in
the billions
um for for the aggregate industry and
like you said they're certain that are
doing there's certain vpns that are
doing hundreds of millions of dollars of
sales and so the name of the game is
just check all the boxes so that no no
VPN reviewer who's independent can like
take you down and be like there's a
fatal flaw and do not use this VPN
because I know for a fact it doesn't do
the right thing but once you've actually
implemented all the features where yes
we do we check all these boxes then it's
just a marketing game and that's why you
see them is it just a commodity like
with I I don't know much about the VPN
Tech like is it uh is it terribly
complicated it is complicated
programming wise like it's it's somewhat
complicated to write the code I guess
but it's not complicated from like
understanding the features the customer
wants you're not trying to create some
sort of and you called it beastvpn so
what's your business idea here yeah I
called it vs VPN I call it Beast VPN
because obviously Mr Beast is the
biggest Creator and he is an interesting
place where he has an international
audience he has a an audience that's
it's just it's just everyone his
audience is everyone and so what's a
product that you can sell all everywhere
across the world that's very high margin
low churn VPN and that's why VPN are
advertising all over YouTube is because
it doesn't matter if the ad is served to
someone in Japan or India or Europe like
the vpn's available there so I'll give
this idea a 9 out of 10. nice what I
like about this idea is exactly what you
said it takes the weakness of Creator
businesses which is you get a bunch of
low value kind of uh subscribers maybe
like you know some the value of a random
subscriber in India random subscriber in
Croatia it's like hard to get ad money
for that type of viewer but this product
is actually even better for
international people than it is for in
the US so I think that's one big
strength and then obviously recurring
Revenue uh digital good or Victoria
Revenue software is obviously amazing I
only give it a nine instead of a ten
just because it's the first idea and I'm
not that easy so I gotta I gotta talk to
one point just on that alone
also to be fair uh it might make more
sense for like a Linus Tech tips and an
MKBHD to do this because they're more of
like tech people we were gonna do this
at milk Road actually when we built the
road we're like okay cool we're making
money we're profitable on just
newsletter ads but I was like what's the
best product we could do I was like what
if we did a crypto a VPN for the crypto
economy because we're at that time we're
you know one of the more trusted Brands
where like it's kind of a commodity
software it's useful for crypto users to
use a VPN and so that was one of my
ideas about we sold before we got around
to doing that that's a good idea that's
a good idea you should have that would
have been cool if you would have done
that that would have been that's a
pretty cool move
too bad
well they still the guys still own milk
Rod so we still own a part of it I'm
gonna tell them after this and be like
hey guys let's revive this I mean the
main thing is that you just have to have
the the distribution you've listed uh
Linus Tech tips on your you said do you
know this guy well no I just saw him so
you said that uh what's the guy's name
Marquis what's that guys what's his
channel MKBHD March yeah I like him
everyone knows him uh he's cool this guy
Linus Tech tips has 15 million
subscribers yeah oh my God what and like
I mean he he has a team that's like you
know I think over a hundred people wow
multiple channels podcasts like
everything he actually built his own
like media platform where you can like
go in and watch videos and and talk to
each other it's like a forum site and he
just released like a screwdriver and
sold like five million dollars of a
screwdriver or something like that yeah
I'm sure I'm sure he did great on that
the question is like would he have done
better if instead of buying a
screwdriver which needed to be bought
probably locally or it was really
expensive to ship internationally he
sold something that was recurring
software that was 99 margin of VPN the
only thing is that honestly the
screwdriver is cooler than a VPN so you
know I can't fault him because the
screwdriver is like you get to build
your hacker you get to put your PC
together like that's fun VPN it's it's a
little boring I use a VPN though I like
vpns all right what you got second idea
yeah so uh
uh the obviously Americans love guns
you're an American you own some guns uh
that's not changing we've seen through
you know the past few decades that like
you're like real like restrictions on
guns are not coming and so the business
is probably pretty durable we've seen
that the the stocks of munition
companies are doing fine over the last
decades
um but the price is increasing a lot of
that's just due to supply chains but
there might be some more structural
issues also just more people are hunting
more people are are buying guns and
buying ammunition and obviously shooting
is just a fun hobby so the the over the
last three years the price of shotgun
shells went from ten dollars to sixteen
dollars pretty big increase and there's
this massive shortage so the the idea
here is basically like maybe you need a
new
um maybe we need to bring some some
efficiency to the ammunition supply
chain and I think it's an interesting
idea
I don't actually know enough about how
to run an Ammunition Depot or ammunition
Factory but what I do know is that the
hottest Trend right now in business is
like Roll-Ups or search funds and every
guy who graduates from HBS is like I'm
gonna go roll up laundromats or I'm
gonna go roll up dentists dentists it's
like everyone has an idea for these
things and they're all very commodity
they're not very contrarian and so
there's probably not a lot of alpha
there but it's like the guy the people
that are coming out of HBS are probably
not saying I'm gonna go roll up weapons
manufacturers and obviously like Android
is crushing it in the Venture side but
they're doing like insane software
Hardware building drones building like
these really Advanced AI powered weapon
systems this is not that you do this
company you buy a bunch of you know all
we do is make shotgun shells you buy
three of them you move the employees
around you kind of optimize things a
little bit it's just like a very boring
life like you know know private Equity
style roll up and then maybe hit a
cruise power over time because obviously
it is a massive industry but you're not
coming in and trying to reinvent the
wheel you're not being like we're going
to actually 3D print the shell or
something no it's just like good
operations there's a lot of gun
YouTubers you know we could we could mix
that oh yeah yeah we could get them in
do you live in California I do I do are
you guys even so I used to live in
California I live in Texas now I I own
guns because I have a ranch and it's fun
for shooting are you guys even allowed
to own guns in California yes we're
allowed to own guns no like what's the
rule uh no no I mean you can there's a
whole bunch of restrictions on like
rifles like certain capacity magazines
but the I think most recently like it's
pretty easy to get a concealed carry
permit in San Francisco it's kind of a
narrative violation wait what I I
thought for years that was impossible
yeah most people think it's like
Unthinkable but in fact it it is
becoming easier which is kind of crazy
um but yeah I mean obviously California
is not like a dream state for for you
know if you're gun fan but
Sean Sean you've been talking about
getting your conceal and carry for years
now right
not at all
um guns scare me but uh I did look at
investing in an ammunition roll-up I'm
trying to find the the deck you did
that's hilarious uh yeah we got
introduced to somebody who was doing it
and I was like I love this idea but it
was so far field uh out of like what I'm
used to investing in that I was like and
I didn't know I was like how do you know
yeah how do you know that they can
actually do the due diligence like if
you can't do the due daily exactly I
don't think I would touch this I
wouldn't touch this either why I
wouldn't want this in my obituary that I
you know even though and I and I and I I
understand how that's hypocritical you
know I criticized Sean because Sean
wants to like invest in only fan
companies and I'm like I'm not touching
that but at the same time I consume porn
so like there's definitely like a little
bit of uh I I acknowledge the hypocrisy
yeah but like you know I guess I guess
you know it doesn't have to be black and
white it's Shades of Gray and like me I
I prefer to stay on the wider of the of
that side yeah yeah I mean that's
totally fair and I think that's why
there might be Alpha in this area
because I think that dummies like you
Sam that's what that's why why this
opportunity exists because that made no
sense they made tons of sense dude what
are you talking about you're like I love
guns I enjoy them I buy them I'm buying
I'm buying the ammunition but you know I
don't want to support I don't want to
invest in it because only bad people
would buy it like what does that mean no
no I didn't say only bad people I said I
don't want to own it I didn't say I said
that I I buy the stuff I use it I think
it's very enjoyable I love shooting for
fun but that doesn't mean I want to make
it my career I mean Sam would would your
opinion change if we were actively at in
a hot War
like it's your duty to America to
optimize the ammunition supply chain
because there are like there there are
troops from you know some country
Landing in the beaches of California
would my opinion change yeah of course
yeah and that's totally fair and my
opinion could change about the whole
thing I'm very open to new uh data
points and changing my opinion uh uh I'm
just saying like yeah like Andrew like I
love Andrew I I like I think that's a
very patriotic Mission but I know 100
owning Remington like right now I'm like
uh I don't know man like yeah I could
probably make money in other ways and my
contest would be a little less like it
would be it's very it's just an easier
decision Sam I got I got a question for
you there's a thing going viral on Tick
Tock right now that's uh girlfriends
asking their boyfriends or you know
wives dads and their husbands something
I'll be the wife here I'm gonna ask you
a question uh that they're asking Hey
when's the last time or how no how often
do you think about the Roman Empire
anything to do with the Roman Empire oh
all the time a lot
like
why under what circumstances would you
need to think about that
just like uh like Gladiators and [__]
just like battling to the death in front
of everyone when's the last time you
thought about something like that like
this week last night I mean the funny
thing here is that like the the meme
immediately before that was like the in
the arena Meme and everyone in Tech was
posting literal like Roman Empire gifs
because everyone in Tech is like
obsessed with the arena and I know that
there are two separate communities like
that's not why the meme popped up but
it's like yeah it's so funny to see all
these women are like they're like they
they see somebody asked the question the
guy answers some exactly almost Verbatim
what Sam just said always always it's
like I'm thinking about it right now all
the time yeah like what do you mean of
course and my wife has a video of that
where I didn't know about the meme and
she takes out her phone videos me is
like oh she asked you think about the
Roman Empire yeah and I was like I'm
thinking about it right now why
and then all the comments are like you
know that makes you know that's crazy
and then they come back reply like I
just asked he said last week he said he
thinks about it twice a week he's like
yeah
they're like I can't fathom why this man
who doesn't take out the trash on time
who forgot to pick up our daughter from
preschool why he is thinking about the
Roman Empire twice a week dude I think
about 9 11 in World War II like 90 of my
day like do you guys not think like what
would I do if I was on that plane you
know what I mean like
think about that constantly I think
about that constantly or like it's just
a very normal masculine urge like
there's this joke Shane girls he's like
just so you know being obsessed with
history particular World War II is a
precursor to becoming a Republican
like you know it's early onset
wait Sean you don't think about like
World War II like on a regular basis no
but I have my own version of it which is
like I'm constantly like I if I walk
into a place
I'm like assessing how if I had to how
would I like Rob this place or like if
some [__] went down like what's the move
all right what's the move okay there's
some sort of like masculine daydreaming
that happens like my buddy David like he
he imagines like ninjas coming through
every door and window and how he would
like take them out tactically like
that's his dude every time I'm in a
baggage claim I'm like
I could take any of these bags right now
and just walk out there is no security
in this place are you kidding me like
the baggage claimed I I will never get
over that why it's so easy to just take
anyone's bag my wife and I got to dinner
we have like a rule Sam's back does not
sit to the front door I have to see the
front door like you know like I can't
have people coming in without me knowing
I've got to see my front door yeah I do
think it's a man thing you know uh John
we there's this funny quote Scott
Galloway said he goes uh
um you should exercise so you can kill
and eat most everyone in a room or be
able to outrun them uh and that's like
at its root that's kind of like what
we're talking about right now yeah yeah
yeah 100 yeah
uh John I want to ask you you
um so Sam is basically like clearly just
like surging on testosterone you uh are
eir at Founders fund which is I remember
at one point when they were talking
about PayPal they said uh oh you know
Max left should interviewed some
engineer back in the early days of
PayPal and then he was like no no can't
hire this guy it's like what he passed
everyone else's test he's like he plays
basketball I don't know any great
program who goes and plays basketball
three times a week that's not a thing
and so they were like very anti-jock um
do you get to hang out with the founders
fun people a lot like do you hang out in
person at all and what's that like
because seems like a room full of very
interesting very different people yeah
it is it's uh It's oddly they've done a
great job of not creating a monoculture
in a very small organization so yeah
there are definitely like complete jocks
that I mean obviously we know Keith for
boys that berries like five times a day
yeah I don't know if I would call Keith
or boy a jock uh but uh like why do you
use like a workout not he's a fitness
nut for sure but berries
yeah he's trying to be the best at
sports you know he's trying to be the
best at exercising why is that okay why
no I'm just joking but why is that guy
why is Keith's boys such a [__] on
Twitter like why does he behave that way
he's he's like needlessly rude I think a
lot of it is just like holding the line
on like like when he sees something
that's like not true he doesn't want to
spread and so he just like shuts it down
like really aggressively yeah he's like
put it he's like he's put his flag in
some silly things like Miami so it's
like if Miami doesn't work it it's like
gonna hurt him and it's like you know it
doesn't have to you know you you could
love it and also it's not the best a lot
of these things are you know I think
learned behaviors I think everyone in
Tech is somewhat
like like just injured from the past
like for sure it's very obvious I'm just
getting like just beat down for every
little thing and so a lot of people have
put up walls and I think that it's time
I agree with you I think it's time to
kind of take down the Walls be a little
bit less defensive generally but I
understand where all these behaviors are
coming from what's Sean Parker up to we
haven't heard about that guy in years
yeah we got to get him back on Twitter
because if you or asked because if you
talk to anyone who knows him they will
just say that he was the greatest poster
of all time who's the best on Twitter
now I mean probably like uh
Rahul ligma Daniel Johnson like those
type of guys right like do you guys
remember that publicity stuff that they
did they fooled CNBC into reporting that
they were Twitter employees that were
fired it was very like that that's just
like you know those guys
um they're like doing a normal startup
they're like building something Deadpool
yeah no they're not like comedians they
should have just gone all in on like oh
[__] we need to just create like this
sort of like um some version of punked
or like uh you know something for the
tech industry they should have just gone
all in as personality I would have
dropped the startup in like six months
sabbatical on the startup I'm just gonna
see what happens if I fully Troll and
like maybe I could be the thing that the
community needs dude Rahul ligma still
makes me like spit water out my nose
when I hear that it's it's so funny it's
so funny
um yeah I don't know I mean how would
you monetize that if they would you just
be doing stand-ups I think it feels like
silent donations from billionaires I've
seen that guy and he only hangs out with
successful billionaires when I've seen
him in person like because everybody who
was big in Tech loved that troll Elon
loved it uh you know like the the
holding guy's like oh my God it's the
best it's the best I feel like they
could have a patreon of billionaires
only that just fund them to like do
statement art uh you know like comedic
statement or against the media against
the local politicians against whatever
that's what I would have done if I was
them that's maybe that's not a bad idea
but I don't know I I like it seems like
they're pretty legit at what they're
doing they're like actually good
programmers
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
you have a thing on this document that I
want to fight you about yeah yeah I knew
this I was getting you again but here's
the so John sent us this document he
says unique philosophies lifestyle
businesses are worthless what do you
make your case
you walk link yeah exactly
no no I I this is mostly just like let's
have a fun debate because I'm like you
know working at a venture capital firm
and I can kind of represent the VC crew
and you guys are like the kings of like
the lifestyle business so we aren't the
kings of that by the way I want to be
the king of it actually I I actually
will accept that compliment I don't mind
being the king of it what I'm saying is
I think that we are one of the very few
kind of content creators you pay proper
respect to it yeah what I'm saying is we
we we we do both we think both are cool
that that's I there's very few people I
think that are in the middle and I think
we are in the middle yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's fair that's fair
um and so yeah basically I I think the
point is just that uh
lifestyle businesses are great Define
that so I would say I I would say like
non-venture-backed non-blit scaling
non-hyperscaling non-monopoly something
without a crazy moat where it's just
like you go and work at it and maybe it
gets really big and maybe you wind up
being a billionaire but you didn't you
didn't like do this growth at all costs
insane thing then what's hyper growth uh
two or three times a year
I mean sometimes 10 times a year right
um it depends on the scale at the early
stages it goes really really fast but I
I'm specifically thinking of like
Facebook right I'm specifically thinking
of the power law outcomes in Venture and
my my point is that basically only about
one percent of companies that get
started raise Venture Capital but about
99 of the market cap in the public
markets they took Venture and so venture
has this very like ass like like
disproportional outcome and I believe
that that the bigger the company the
bigger the impact on the world and so if
you want to have a really really big
impact you should actually be trying to
raise money grow very grow very quickly
like you're not going to build a hundred
billion dollar company compounding it
two percent a year five percent a year
over your lifetime it just won't happen
all right let me play the other side of
that please your analogy of well okay so
you're saying one percent uh or 90 uh 99
of the value is created by the one
percent of companies that raise money so
that to me is also saying that like look
um
100 of the soldiers on D-Day who ended
up uh killing like the Nazis that ended
that battle they had to land on that
beach anyway right so you might as well
lay on that beach and I'm like yeah but
the other one's got like [__] killed
and destroyed how about I just like not
worry about killing Nazis and like I
could just like start this little thing
on the side you know what I mean like
it's like it's like dude like this whole
thing with like VC it's like you're
funding all the you as the investor are
funding all these companies and you're
like dude I don't give a [__] which one
of you dies out here because I know one
of you is gonna like make me my money
and so from my perspective I'm like yeah
so if I can get rich at with a higher
likelihood which is maybe uh in most
cases the number one reason for starting
a business in not most cases like other
cases it's like the number three version
let's say your number one version is
like I want to like create change
getting rich is still up there so like
if like if you can get rich and create
value and have fun and work for yourself
and have a higher likelihood of doing
that
why wouldn't you go that route so so the
reason I think you shouldn't go with
that route is because I think your
overall impact on humanity and society
and the world will be lower if if it
survives yeah this whole question of
would you rather own 100 of a 100
million dollar company or one percent of
a 10 billion dollar company I don't even
think it's a question obviously the 10
billion dollar company because the 10
billion dollar company is having a much
larger impact on the world that quite
that's that's not an obvious answer but
no no no it's not it's not for for a lot
of people they say I would rather have
100 and be able to go on vacation and
you know chill and just have these cash
flows come directly to me and not have
to deal with like you know all this
other stuff and I get that but my point
is that like I believe that humans have
a duty to each other to go and have the
largest impact possible and that is
often done with the backing of venture
capitalists I don't think you believe
that yeah I do wouldn't you not be like
uh curing cancer instead of selling
nicotine gum like let's uh let's be
honest uh oh well I mean that's
hilarious that you use that as an
example because that's like the actually
the best way to stop lung cancer is to
get people to switch right yeah but
don't let facts get the way of a good
argument but but I I will actually
synthesize this for you and I think we
will agree on this point which is that
what you should actually do with your
life is pick the hardest most
interesting most value creative problem
that you are equipped to solve so can I
create a cancer curing drug no I don't
have that background it's not an option
for me so I would fail if I went into
that industry but I should pick the most
ambitious thing and the best idea that I
have and then I should be very rigorous
about whether or not that idea is
appropriate for venture capital and I
think that if Mark Zuckerberg didn't
raise Venture Capital his company would
be dead and I think there's a lot of
companies I've been a part of some of
them where we raise cut we raise VC for
com for a company that didn't need BC
and it also killed the company I think
so basically you have to you have to
pick the best idea that you're equipped
to solve and then decide the financing
strategy that aligns with that and
there's no one-size-fits-all solution do
you wish you would have done a different
idea instead of soylent or do you wish
that you just hadn't taken VC and you
got wealthy oh I don't know that's
interesting I mean right before someone
I was working on natural language
generation in 2013 which is like the
hottest Trend now and so if I'd probably
just like stuck with that for a decade
I'd probably be doing something cool
right now maybe you I I think that you
would have been more impactful if
Soylent has it hadn't raised and you had
gotten rich and then you would have been
able to like say like something else
well you would have been like I don't
care about money as much so I'll just do
this other crazy thing that is a
moonshot like I I think it's I because I
took a similar argument as you yeah and
then uh someone corrected me and they're
like yeah but it's a lot easier to go
after moonshine ideas when you don't
worry about a mortgage and as someone
who had a bootstrap exit I agree I'm
like
it's pretty like I understand why
Founders uh want to take secondary
because you are more dangerous when you
have 10 or 20 or 30 million dollars like
you are more dangerous when you don't
worry or you're like I'm rich enough
that I don't have to worry but I'm not
rich enough that I want to stop yeah I
would 100 feel like I'm in that category
like that that puts you in a dangerous
category I think yeah I 100 feel that
I'm in that category and and thus
because that's true I think lifestyle
businesses are awesome oh because it can
get you there faster yeah yeah for sure
yeah yeah get like the base hit before
you do the big thing yeah not
unreasonable and and I think that's also
kind of a synthesis of what we're saying
we kind of agree but that it's like
moonshots are good but but the path
might be circuitous to them right and
there are freaks out there like an Elon
like a Zuck well I don't know about Zack
but like an Elon who's willing to risk
it all yeah even Elon like PayPal could
be framed as like less ambitious than
SpaceX and Tesla right it's like the
mission might not be as big who knows
well he tweeted this out the other day
uh and so Andrew Wilkinson had had
tweeted something out like this that was
like uh you know um you know he learned
learn to crawl or learn to walk before
you run yeah he's like most most people
want to do a big crazy ambitious thing
should start by doing a smaller thing so
they learn how to do business and then
do you know make things happen and then
graduate up and a bunch of people were
agreeing with him
I totally disagreed I was like if you
know the thing you want to do
you should just go do the thing you know
the way that doing something before you
do your bigger thing works well I
believe is at first that was the biggest
thing you knew and then as you did it
your world view expanded and your
ambition expanded and you're the set of
possibilities you were aware of expanded
and then you went and did that thing
however Elon did reply almost uh
confirming what Andrew had said for him
in his case he was like yeah you know I
couldn't have created SpaceX if I didn't
have the money and the skills and
reputation as I had during zip2 and
specifically somebody had said that like
they had talked to Elon and he you know
I don't believe this for the record I
don't believe a word of this but they
were like yeah I talked to Elon early on
and or I talked to Elon and he said that
early on he decided oh I want to die on
Mars just not he said the following I
would like to die on Mars just not on
impact
um and you know that's like his joke and
then he's like and I decided the way to
do that was I needed a lot of money
um and so then I went to the internet
just to go get the money quickly you
know as quickly as I could I don't
believe that to be true because
um
you know first of all not everybody is
like that much of a mastermind you know
when he was like sleeping under his desk
as like a college kid I don't think that
he was like
being like I'm only doing this so that I
can amass a fortune to launch three
spaceships you know to be able to fund
three of my own ships like I don't
believe that also he went and did X
after zip two so it's like oh if you you
already had you know whatever the you
know I don't know what he said I think
like something like 60 or 80 million
dollars out of zip two
um like
it'd be surprising to me if he was like
you know what it's not gonna be enough I
need to go get to 250 million that's the
magic number yeah there's a big question
about yeah like like should you ever
sell a company because if if your real
goal in life is to have an impact on the
world maybe the company is the best way
to do that and so you should just
continue to run your company endlessly I
mean you guys we everyone on this call
sold companies well my goal is very
simple yeah yeah what's your goal you
said like if you want to have Maximum
Impact on the world that is not my goal
and so it's very easy for me to just be
like oh cool I can rule that out I'm
trying to have the best lifestyle that I
could have that is my selfish and very
transparent goal I am trying to improve
my quality of life and with that comes
my family's quality of life with that
might come living in a good place and
being being a happy content person
walking around the world is my
contribution to society I don't feel the
obligation to go save the world but
personally I mean the beauty of that is
that like by you will naturally have a
positive impact on the World by
doing what you do to achieve those ends
it might not be as big as oh you got us
you cured cancer got us to Mars but like
there's going to be economic activity
that provides value and utility to
various people as you like go about your
business and as long as you have like a
moral compass that doesn't that doesn't
result in you doing something really
unethical like you'll probably have a
net positive view on society like my
trainer has a great way of saying this
he goes uh you know we I was like yeah
my goal is to like have an amazing
lifestyle quality of life right that's
my my number one like you know why I do
things is around that does this improve
my quality of life oh if I go do this
thing I'm stressed out all the time and
I have meetings all the time and I don't
see my kids no no you've it is not
improved my quality of life but he said
the other the other thing he said is
mutually beneficial so that all the
things I do are mutually beneficial to
the people that interact with this if I
make a product it needs to be mutually
beneficial to them if I have a partner
or I interact with somebody it needs to
be mutually beneficial and so that's the
only caveat that we added to it let's
make it you know work is your personal
trainer like your life coach do yeah oh
yeah that's like a that's a recurring
thing is Sean's personal trader John you
uh you're cool because you um I think
you're like us uh but maybe even more
extreme in the tech world than that you
have your foot in the startup world and
you're hanging out with these bigwigs
but you're also can just joke around and
shoot the [__] and like you're pretty
self-aware
who uh what do you align with who do you
align with politically oh uh yeah I I
really like this guy Mark Hurd who's a
republican from Texas uh he was uh he's
a smaller candidate so he's not pulling
super well but he worked for the CIA and
he also was on the board of palantir and
he would be the first computer scientist
president and I think that that would
just be very very interesting to see
someone with a CS background obviously I
love programmers and I I think that they
think about the world in very
interesting ways and we've had this very
long long Arc of you know lawyer lawyer
businessman lawyer lawyer lawyer right
like that's the story and he's like a
younger guy so uh I'm I'm proud to
endorse him are you more Republican than
Democrat or do you vote both yeah yeah I
vote both it just kind of depends on who
is who can have like the highest impact
on mostly technology and the business
Community I think that those are kind of
the the the things that we need to be
thinking about I do think there's the
interesting
um as I look back on Trump I didn't vote
for him didn't support him voted against
him twice but
um but I think that there's this weird
situation where like the problems that
Trump brought were obviously really bad
I think you really like divided the
country and just created a lot of chaos
and I think that was like probably net
negative for the United States but he
did kind of get China right and he
started this like he got people waking
up about the fact that we are in a great
power competition again and so you could
see a world where the China situation
dissipates and things get better and
that would be phenomenal for the world
and that's what I hope happens and in
that case Trump will be remembered as
like an idiot basically but the opposite
could also happen where the China
situation gets hotter and then people
look back to Trump as like a like a
genius who foresaw this all and like
took the first steps to like make things
safe and so I think the what's
interesting is that though the way we
remember presidents is often not by what
they actually did but by how their
decisions look in hindsight and it comes
back to the you know don't judge
Adventure investment until it's 20 years
later 10 years later it's the same thing
it's like like maybe we shouldn't judge
our presidents until we you know with
the full History of Time
you had said something earlier about
like you were working on natural
language generation in 2013 yeah
um now these large language model llms
are all the rage and you had an idea
around this that I liked because it was
very different than how most people most
investors talk about this so you had
said something like everybody is uh
knocking certain AI startups because
they're oh it's just a wrapper on top of
GPT it's just a wrapper on top of what
open AI is doing it's a flimsy little
thing you had a different take what's
your take yeah my take is that
that might be a reasonable critique for
a growth stage venture capitalist to
debate with their Partners at an
investment committee meeting that is not
necessarily what we should be putting
out on Twitter x to the next generation
of young Builders and if you are you
know I I know a lot of these kids who
are 17 18 19 and they're hacking and
building chat GPT wrappers and some of
them are making a ton of money and it's
fine what's an example yeah I mean like
an example would be like
um like just just narrowing down to
something very there are a few people
that have done like uh like almost like
dating coaching kind of like uh to help
with if you're bad at texting there was
a whole South Park episode about this
which was pretty funny yeah yeah like if
you're if you don't know what to text
someone on like a dating app you can
have like you could go to chatgpt and
say hi I'm on Tinder and I I need to
send a response to this girl and I'm
feeling awkward like what should I say
and it'll give you a recommendation but
these apps have kind of like fine-tuned
it to be a little bit more like spicy or
you know engaging or whatever homework
help they'll do rap lyrics they'll do
whatever right yeah and I I don't I
don't know the details about those but a
lot of people will be like oh those
aren't appropriate for Venture Capital
therefore like they should not be built
and this is kind of where I'm
flip-flopping to my you know Lifestyles
or bad it's like no actually these are
phenomenal because we need these these
like people to get experience building
and I think maybe I think about it even
less from the economic side and more
from just the experiential side of like
if if you ever talk to somebody who's
like they were able to
you know run some small business when
they were in high school that's always a
bull signal for entrepreneurship like
there it's always like oh you're and now
you're doing the Venture back thing it's
going to make a lot of money like it
doesn't matter what the thing was right
it's like oh I was hustling sneakers or
oh I was like selling reselling uh
concert tickets like my thing was I
bought DJ equipment in the United States
and then I would export it to Australia
and I was just like hustling that stuff
in high school like everyone has one of
these stories I'm sure you guys have
tons that you've told on the Pod
um but so so basically with the with the
uh we need I want the lens uh for chat
GPT moment so lenza for those of you who
might not remember was I don't know what
that is so so it's this app that you
would download and you'd upload you know
10 selfies of yourself from your camera
roll yeah and then it would generate AI
images that looked like you so it would
be like it that looks like Sam's face
but it's on Superman or it was like but
it was really like a Russian company
that was that was the rumors that it was
a Russian company I think that one was
but yeah I mean there are some weird
like these apps come from all over I'm
not sure about lenza um I I think I
don't I I just haven't looked into the
company but and it made a bunch of money
it was like number one in the app store
for a bit yeah yeah it was based on it
was based on stable diffusion which is
this open source software package and
dream Booth which was this paper that
Google put out that then people went and
implemented like no one knew what those
things meant no one your aunt doesn't
know what stable diffusion or lens or
dream Booth is but she probably
downloaded and paid for lenza magic
avatars and had that as a profile
picture for a little bit so it's just
like this this fun viral moment that was
really successful and I think that
there's a lot of people who I would hate
if they're toying around with chat GPT
and they don't build something that's
really fun and cool because they're like
oh well this won't be like a hyperscaler
combining like generational company it's
like maybe you just need to go build the
fun thing and put it out there and see
how it goes what would be something you
build so I have an idea about this which
is basically that there's a few things
that these that these systems are really
good at you know obviously there's been
huge progress in helping software
developers program with GitHub co-pilot
which is you know built by openai under
the hood there's also you know just the
Google use case like I go to chatgpt all
the time just ask it questions that I
would normally ask Google
um people are doing a lot of like AI
girlfriend stuff like you know shot I'm
sure your your next uh your next big uh
only fans investment will have an AI
component probably but but I think that
the that one of the interesting things
that these language models are
particularly good at is something called
the Barnum effect have you guys heard
about this no so the Barnum effect is
this psychological phenomenon where
like I can say a like something that
sounds like it's very specifically
tailored to you but it's actually vague
and applies to everyone so so an example
of this would be
um Sam you have a great need for other
people to like and admire you you have a
tendency to be critical of yourself you
have a great deal of unused capacity
which you have not turned into your
advantage like these things resonate
with everyone they certainly resonate
with me I feel like yep yep yep but and
they feel personalized it's like
astrology yeah yeah they use this in
astrology and so what I'm thinking is
like someone should take the you know
chat GPT llms and make some sort of like
viral personality quiz viral astrology
app something along those lines that
Miss Cleo yeah that X that exploits this
effect that llms are really really good
at and then and then uses it it's just
like yeah you oh yeah did you get your
personalities it's like did you get your
lens of magic avatars like yeah I got
them like I had to do in-app payment it
was 5.99 it's like oh did you well did
you get your custom personality test
through this chat bot that's new and
going viral like yeah sure I did that I
think that's a great prediction I think
that's gonna happen uh very soon and
this we'll look back at this clip and be
like dude he called it John called it
that was gonna happen it has to happen
uh somebody said this the other day they
go
um they showed me under they showed me a
Steve Jobs clip and Steve Jobs goes
once this technology happened
um the there was a set of 20 things that
were going to happen no matter what it
didn't matter who was gonna do them they
were going to happen a series of events
were going to unfold once that
breakthrough once that first
breakthrough happened and you just
didn't know when and you didn't know who
but you definitely knew that they were
going to happen that's how I feel about
this idea I love it
I'm glad I I'm glad I got the thumbs up
on all my all my yeah your ideas were
actually very very uh very solitary you
you said you did your high school
flipping thing uh you also were a uh uh
what was it called like a phone a
telephone marketing scam artist
tell that story we'll wrap on that so
this is a phenomenal story what do you
like Workaholics uh yeah yeah a little
bit I I use the office as a reference
point because that is the the default
like small business in America
um you know they make a thing and then
they ship it out and so the scam worked
like this I found the job on Craigslist
I show up and I'm wearing a suit I'm
probably 17 years old or something and
I'm like I brought a resume I want this
job and they're like uh it's not that
type of job like you do not need to be
wearing a suit just sit over there
you're going to call these numbers call
down the list and when they pick up read
this script and the script goes like
something like this I probably still
remember it by heart but um it was like
uh when they pick up you do not ask how
they're doing you do not talk to them
you just say shipping Department please
and you want to make it sound like
you've been disconnected like I was
already talking to the shipping
Department half the time people are like
what are you talking about this is a law
firm we don't have a shipping department
but
the other half of the time people are
like yeah we got a shipping Department
I'll transfer you down there like you
must have just gotten disconnected then
you're down in the shipping department
so imagine Dunder Mifflin from the
office you know you just talked to Pam
Pam transferred you down to I think
Daryl is down in the shipping Department
right and now you're talking to the guys
down in the shipping department and uh
the the scam was selling two inch clear
tape so the guy picks up from the
shipping department so the shipping
Department you know John here uh or
Daryl and and then you say hey you're
you guys are still using the two inch
clear tape right that was the line so
this is the secret it's like it's like
asking an office they use eight and a
half by eleven inch paper or like asking
you know a podcaster like do you still
use microphones you know it's like yes
everyone uses two inch clear tape in a
shipping Department because what you use
to just tape boxes it's a clear tape
that you use to pack things packing tape
and so they're obviously going to say
yes but it sounds like you've already
sold to them you know you're still using
the two inch clear tape right we didn't
say that we sold you but then then if
they say yes then you say
um you know hey I I just want to you
know like thank you not for being a
customer just thank you I want to thank
you and we're going to send out I want
to send out another box of that two inch
clear tape uh for you guys and I'm gonna
throw in a Starbucks gift card for you
personally your name's gonna be on it
this one's for you and I and and they're
running me through this I'm like how
much is the Starbucks gift card for I'm
like uh I I need information I'm like
obsessive about information and so he's
like don't worry about it and I'm like
no but like I need to know because like
what if they ask me they'll never ask
you and I was like no but I I have to
know like I just I cannot do this job
unless you tell me and he was finally
like it's five dollars it's like wow so
so they so they you know they do like
the Starbucks gift card thing they get
the guy to say you know yes I'd like you
know I'm still using it send it out and
then they send it out with an invoice so
you don't need to collect the credit
card details over the phone they send it
out with the invoice and they've priced
this clear tape at exactly the level
that they think most accounting
accounting departments will just stamp
it so it was 500 for a box of clear tape
and it costs them five dollars to
produce this tape how much money did the
company make millions I mean the guys
were like driving around in sports cars
like and I ran the numbers and it was
like you know while I was there I only
worked there for one day and then like I
quit because I was like this is a scam I
figured it out like almost immediately
but a lot of people stuck around like
you know but even then I think I think I
sold a thousand dollars of clear tape
and they're just trying to get the one
sale and the conversion rate is insane
yeah so so they send out I talked to the
guys in our shipping Department of the
scam and and and I first off hilarious
the guys don't use their own clear tape
because it just falls apart it just
disintegrates it's like the worst
product they buy the stuff that gets
thrown away in China basically like like
if they have manufacturing defects
that's what they buy for like 10 cents
and then they sell that for 500 which is
already an order of magnitude more than
you could just get from Staples are they
are they still doing this scam I don't
know I I don't think so they had like an
F from the Better Business Bureau and
then like I imagine that it like
dissolved or they probably got like all
their phone numbers blocked or something
what did these guys look like did they
look like what I think they would look
like
they actually looked exactly like the
three of us
yeah exactly I think I think the I think
the CEO had your jacket sound he was
wearing black teacher like you drive a
black Escalade yeah yeah probably no I I
think I think they were doing like Audi
R8s I think that was like the big move
there's some guy listening to this
that's in a shipping Department that
just had a holy [__] moment he's like
we've been dead the tape guy who keeps
calling me those gift cards and then
there's like and then there's like a
thousand other people are like so how do
I get the leads to the shipping company
I'm in the same business now boys
[Laughter]
I I ran into a guy who'd worked there a
year later and he was he came up to me I
was at a concert and and he was like oh
John like I Remember You The tall guy
like how's it going I was like remind me
where we know each other from he's like
Delta shipping and I was like oh yeah I
worked there for like a day like what's
up like are you still there he's like no
they fired me they fire everyone like
every three months because they need to
turn people over because as soon as one
person finds out it's a scam they will
tell everyone else it's the same thing
with like a pyramid scheme or a Ponzi
scheme like you gotta like extra you
gotta like you know get out anyone who
knows the truth and keep the blinders on
everyone who's there because as soon as
as soon as one person figures out
they're gonna tell other people and be
like don't you think it's kind of
unethical what we're doing or don't you
think this is like what if the police
come like would we be in trouble you
know and then that scares everyone and
then the whole thing the whole well is
poisoned so I'm like oh you got fired
like that's I'm sorry man that's tough
like what are you doing now hopefully
you got like a better job he's like yeah
I'm selling drugs at this concert
good deal that's amazing you uh tell
people what your YouTube channel is and
also tell us why are you doing YouTube
you could be going out there building
another business but you're like us your
create content so tell people what the
channel is and why you do it yeah I mean
basically just bored during the pandemic
had always been I mean our first viral
success at Soylent was you know content
and content's super important for
launching companies and I'm an
entrepreneur so having a voice is very
important in that equation
um my YouTube channel you can find it
just John Coogan's search there I also
have a podcast now
powerlaw.fm powerlaw hosted by John
Coogan
um not an interview show it's just kind
of deep Dives on these power law people
and companies these really good names
and that's good titles that's a good
idea yeah so it's it's interesting it's
uh yeah it's a lot of fun I just I
really like it and
um yeah check it out and I I the biggest
problem with it is that I don't have a
lot of focus I'll talk about geopolitics
my last video was on Doug jumuro like
breaking down his business like I just
I'm all over the place but uh but it's
not much fun and like there's clearly
value in what we do like people enjoy it
makes them happy and you meet
interesting people we got to have a
great conversation because of it you
know we appreciate you coming on this
has been really fun you're uh you're
cool man we we uh this has been awesome
we appreciate it hey and we don't have a
lot of focus either look we went from
scams to who are you gonna vote for to
guns you know this is I I this is like
you your your audience you won't be
perfectly optimized like oh we're like
the best ever but in terms of the
lifestyle like we all agree like this is
the way to run the content machine don't
don't go too crazy with it well thank
you we appreciate it and uh thanks for
coming on and that's the pod
[Music]
foreign